Ciao Mariners e benvenuti in questo nuovissimo
videooooooooooo
Oggi parleremo di Capodanno
Piccola premessa sul capodanno allora da ragazzini chiaramente è il capodanno tipo è l'evento della vita lo aspettiamo con ansia
E pensiamo che succeda chissà cosa poi alla fine è un giorno come un altro e quindi
Pace e amore e fantasia che il capodanno è un giorno come tutti gli altri dovete si chiaro festeggiare sempre nei limiti
senza pensare che succeda chissà cosa perché semplicemente
L'ultimo giorno, dell'anno . Partirei subito
Consolando chi mi sta guardando in questo momento e odia il capodanno
Oppure ha passato ovviamente dei capodanni ceh negli ultimi anni dei capodanni tremendi non Sapete cosa vi
aspetta sì perché davanti a voi in questo momento avete la regina dei capodanni flop ma cose dico
l'imperatrice
dell'universo dei capodanni flop.
Il primo capodanno flop vi voglio raccontare
è sicuramente
Epico, passerà alla storia. Se mi chiedono un capodanno da raccontare io racconto sempre quello perché mi fa molto ridere adesso
Quell'anno lì un po' meno io ero una ragazzina avevo tipo
14 o 15 anni
e
Avevo questo fidanzatino di cui chiaramente ero innamorata persa ed era più grande di me; allora vi descrivo un attimo la tipologia di ragazzino
proprio quello delle serie tv
biondino
Fisichino carino e insomma era il bonazzo della compagnia il Justin Bieber della compagnia
io ero innamorata persa
un giorno miracolosamente
Succede che questo ragazzino mi chiede di fidanzarci e quindi le campane suonarono a festa gli usignoli
mularono, nel buio della mia vita e io mi fidanzai con questo ragazzo
E voi vi confermerete che quando ti fidanzate con un ragazzo cioè proprio Gli occhi a cuoricino tutto bellissimo
Cosa succede dopo tipo un mese? Mi lascia
E io cado
nelle tenebre
dell'abbandono e voi direte ci siamo passate tutte
sì ma non avete ancora
Scoperto il clou. Del discorso e cioè il capodanno
qualche mese dopo
Ma neanche troppi mesi cioè sono stati due mesi dopo era capodanno e io con la mia compagnia
Avevo deciso di passare il capodanno. Nella casa di campagna. Della mia migliore amica
Immaginate quando la mia migliore amica mi guarda mi dice vedi che c'è anche
X cioè il mio ex viene a fare capodanno qui
COSAA?
Era arrivato il momento di
Riconquistarlo perché lui a capodanno mi avrebbe visto più bella che mai e ci sarebbe di nuovo innamorato
Di me mi avrebbe chiesto scusa per quei Due mesi di completo abbandono e io chiaramente avrei ceduto
tornando con lui
Arriva, il famoso capodanno immaginatevi una marina adolescente combinata stile Ariana Grande
questo trucco ha fatto 30 mila volte peggio però avete capito
Il mood ma mi sentivo veramente veramente
Figa e mi confermerete voi da casa che quando c'è il ragazzino di cui siete innamorata
Ci pensi sette mesi prima cosa metterti o a come combinarti insomma era stato un lungo percorso
verso quella sera di capodanno ed io ero pronta a vederlo pronta a
riconquistarlo inizia il capodanno
E dopo ore lui ancora non c'è di lui non c'è traccia
Io li cado in depressione perché dico non verrà più e proprio quando ormai avevo completamente
Perso le speranze
Lo vedo
Lo vedo in tutto il suo splendore
Colpito da un raggio da un fascio di luce che insomma lo illumina e mi indica la strada verso il paradiso
Lui mi guarda mi sorride io
mi sciolgo
Ed è proprio lì che
dietro di lui
vedo
LA SUA NUOVA FIDANZATA
Erano mesi che aspettavo quel giorno per riconquistarlo mi ero programmata e preparata tutto il discorso
Ma non c'era niente da fare perché lui era lì con una sorta di barbie
californiana bionda
abbronzata manco invece alle mauritius è
Perfetta ecco io in quel momento mi son sentita una cacchina
Devo andare via ma dove andavo grandi in mezzo alla campagna
Ma, ahimè non è finito qui perché nel pacchetto comprensivo. Del capodanno . Nella casa di campagna
C'era, anche il pigiama party perché avremo dormito tutti lì ecco
Non, so se avete presente
Le case di campagna sommando queste camere grosse ecc... ecc.. e la camera dei genitori era stata chiusa quindi c'era sotto una camera per tutti
quindi
Immaginate che insomma lui si è fermato a dormire con
lei
e io non potevo scappare perché non c'erano proprio non c'era modo di scappare una ragazzina non potevo chiamare mia mamma e dirle
Prendere perché c'è lui eccetera eccetera insomma mi ama non. Sapeva neanche in questa storia quindi
Il momento più. Flop del capodanno non è stato quando io l'ho visto con
Lei ma è stato quando io ho dovuto dormire
nella stessa stanza in cui dormivano loro due e
sentire per tutta la notte
I loro limoni duri e
Vi assicuro che adesso rido ma c'era molto da piangere immaginatevi una ragazzina col cuore infranto nel bel mezzo. Del capodanno
Assolutamente da dimenticare
Questo era insomma il top. Del flop ma c'è sempre un altro flop che vorrei raccontarvi a proposito di capodanno
Qualche anno  dopo il capodanno che vi ho appena raccontato
Non avevo alcun programma perché non aveva uno straccio di fidanzato
Le mie amiche avevano già tutti organizzato eccetera eccetera
Grazie a dio c'era la mia migliore amica che come sempre
Mi salva nei momenti critici
È la mia migliore amica era stata invitata a un capodanno in montagna appunto a casa dei suoi amici che io non conoscevo
quindi immaginatevi la situa
la mia migliore amica
il suo fidanzato
Altre 3 mie amiche E i loro fidanzati
In una casa in montagna
piena di gente che non conoscevo
Però voi mi confermerete che a volte le situazioni che meno ti aspetti possono
Essere molto divertenti possono essere delle piacevoli sorprese
Ecco questa non è stata perché io sono arrivata in quella casa appunto in alta montagna quindi, non
È che dice c'è un'alternativa me ne va. Da un'altra parte ero
Li in questa  baita e c'era c’era  un gruppo di ragazzi
Appunto della nostra età una trentina di persone che vi assicuro avevano la faccia della morte
musica non c'era almeno quando ero arrivata non c'era poi dopo l'hanno messa perché chiaramente ho
insistito
Cibo c'era ma nessuno lo mangiava quindi un gruppo di ragazzi tutti a dieta l'allegria e la voglia di festeggiare
Non c'era assolutamente proprio non era pervenuta
quindi mi sono sentita in qualche modo
Di animare un po la situa
Voi immaginate le immaginatemi lì dentro insomma da dove si inizia quando la situazione così smorta inizi con la musica
cosa mettevo di musica è che potevo mettere l'ala usa queste musiche qui insomma
Che dopo un po suo nome sono la bella per scaldare la pista no? raffaella carrà
Dai ragazzi insomma mi hanno guardato tutti male cioè io ho portato mio spirito festivo da serata pop trash anni 80 90
70 revival
Nessuno mi ha capita quindi io l'ho detto adesso esploderà la festa sarò la regina
Della serata perché tutti mi ringrazieranno di questo questo sprint di questo sprizzo di allegria
Mi, hanno guardato malissimo
Cioè proprio mi sono vergognata come mai in vita mia ma non. È che ho spento tutte me
Ne sono andata perché come detto prima non c'era modo di andarsene niente io me ne sono fregato ragazzi perché
Il bello della vita essere se stessi e quindi ho ballato
tutta la sera
Da raffaella carrà a sabrina salerno alle spicegirl  a britney spears e non me ne fregava niente di nessuno
Fino a quando è arrivato il momento del brindisi
Perché se fino a quel momento ci diciamo mi ero fatto andare bene
La situazione ero lì che cercavo un attimo di tirare e mezzo le persone
senza riuscirci
quando è arrivato il momento del brindisi
Diciamo che tutta la mia voglia di festeggiare nonostante la gente non avesse voglia di festeggiare è andata un attimo a quel paese
perché
3......2......1
auguri
erano tutte coppie
Solo se fino a quel momento pensavo che soltanto le mie amiche fossero tutte a coppie quindi ho pensato sono l'unica
sfigata da vere amiche tutte fidanzate
Mi sono resa conto che tutta la casa
era accoppiata ragazzi ero l'unica single tutti si
sbaciucchiavano e io
immaginatevi così...
Cappellino cappellino in testa di quelli capodanno trombetta di una storia triste e
Raffaella Carrà di sottofondo io penso che con questa immagine possiamo concludere capodanni più from di marina